[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
webb est venu à paroles autochtone qui
s'est mise à mal depuis sept semaines
avant de commencer ma chronique
j'aimerais vraiment adresser une pensée
par particulièrement profonde pour la
james mee tu cries nation qui aux quatre
jours on vit présentement un moment
extrêmement dramatique avec
aussi beaucoup de personnes qui se sont
retrouvées
à l'hôpital tenon des soins critiques
bien sûr je vais attendre d'avoir plus
d'information pour peut-être pouvoir en
parler mais pour l'instant j'aimerais
quand même adressé parce que quand on
est en deuil quand on vit un drame comme
ça dans une communauté c'est toute la
communauté qui est affectée donc c'est
vécu vraiment de façon intense et c'est
encore quelque chose qui des fois manque
dans les médias d'avoir une vision
profonde des hors jeu mais pour
l'instant si je veux tourner la
chronique cette semaine sur un hors jeu
qui touchent à peu près toute la
communauté ici au québec
particulièrement c'est que les élections
provinciales ont commencé on le sait on
a beaucoup parlé du vote autochtone on
parle beaucoup aussi du fait que cette
année il ya neuf représentants
autochtones aux élections dans
différents partis le parti cannes et le
cannet le plus c'est québec solidaire
avec cinq représentants mais la caq
aussi à une représentante qui est
d'origine autochtone un peu partout on
le voit le vote mais surtout la
représentation autochtone dans les
élections commencent à prendre du chemin
on l'avait vu pendant les élections
fédérales avec un nombre record de 77
représentation autochtone à travers le
pays dans les élections bien sûr l'on
parle de la province dont on diminue un
peu les chiffres mais surtout aussi et
une incompréhension pourquoi est ce que
les élections fédérales me mobilise plus
que les élections provinciales
alors j'essaye souvent d'en faire un
espèce de contexte c'est qu'il faut pas
oublier au québec particulièrement on a
eu le droit de vote seulement en 1969
les communautés autochtones donc le
droit de vote n'est pas aussi
nécessairement y est on va voter on veut
participer aux élections c'est vraiment
vu aussi comme un moment de
est-ce qu'on et colonise est ce que on a
été assimilée au point si nous donne le
droit de vote il faut pas oublier aussi
que pendant très longtemps
prendre ce droit de voir au canada
voulait dire justement qu'on laissait
aller notre statut et des bons
laisser-aller notre identité comme
personne autochtone donc c'était vu
comme un geste colonisats pas et les
gens ne participait pas aux élections
encore aujourd'hui c'est des noms très
minime qui participent dans les
élections que ce provincial ou fédéral
si je me trompe pas en 2018 il ya eu
environ 12 à 15% de populations des
communautés autochtones qui ont voté
vers ce sont environ 66% de la
communauté
globale qui ont voté pendant les
élections provinciales bien sûr on dit
allez communauté votre pas de toute
façon leur tour de représentation est
aussi important que ça dans leur compte
et blabla mais là on le voit de plus en
plus non ils ont un impact les votes
vectone on le voit aux états unis on le
vit au canada ça peut transformer le
visage d'un pays un vote qui est
autochtone et je vous invite à vous y
intéressez d'ailleurs mais on revient au
québec parce que présentement il ya des
conflits quand même très large qui sont
représentés avec beaucoup de personnes
autochtones et même des personnes
autochtones qui sont en opposition les
unes avec les autres dans ces mêmes
comptes et donc ça va être très
intéressant de voir est ce que ça va
mobiliser le vote autochtone est ce que
ça va faire pencher des parties d'un
côté ou blonde bien sûr on aime être
représentés on aime que nos enjeux sont
soit touchée d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
que pendant longtemps le fédéral était
un un des endroits où ce qu'on votait le
plus puisque pendant longtemps justement
les enjeux autochtones faisait partie de
la responsabilité constitutionnelle du
fédéral mais plus on avance plus on se
rend compte que le provincial aussi du
travail à faire sur ces enjeux
autochtones c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
dans le parti faisant halte devant le
parti ou dans le passé les partis qui
étaient provinciaux appuyé souvent les
enjeux autochtones parce qu'il ne se
sentait pas concernée par les appuis
qu'il donnait savait pas d'impact sur
leur politique leur responsabilité mais
plus on avance et plus on se rend compte
par exemple dans des dossiers comme
celui du caribou dans les dossiers par
rapport au saumon à l'hydroélectricité
l'enjeu autochtone commence à toucher
vraiment très sérieusement le provincial
et donc ce n'est plus vue avec et on
vous appuyez mais plus avec ok comment
est ce qu'on peut faire une stratégie
autour de l'implication des communautés
autochtones dans le vote au provincial
chaque province est différente chaque
enjeu environnemental ou de ressources
naturelles qui touchent des communautés
autochtones indifférent au québec c'est
certain que dans les dernières années ce
que j'entends c'est qu'il eût vraiment
encore une négligence de la part du
gouvernement provincial envers les
enjeux autochtones n'auraient ils sont
mais quand même beaucoup d'avancement
aussi sur d'autres sujets d'autres
enjeux particulièrement parce qu'on
parle de représentation au vote par les
communautés autochtones mais on néglige
souvent combien de la participation
globale
compte aussi le vote autochtone urbain
donc les enjeux des personnes
autochtones en milieu urbain de plus en
plus il faut commencer à prendre la
place mais aussi le vote des personnes
qui habitent en milieu urbain qui sont
autochtones vont aussi est influencé par
les choix que justement les partis
politiques mon frère dans les enjeux
autochtones qui touche les communautés
il faut pas négliger ce moi
particulièrement je vote au milieu
urbain donc mon vote va être vraiment
influencé aussi par les chouettes - en
fait pour ma communauté pour la relation
qu'ils ont avec les chefs avec les
enjeux qui touchent nos communautés sur
le territoire donc ça va vraiment venir
influencer ce que je veux faire comme
choix de vote électoral alors voyez
c'est très passionnant très excitant on
va voir vraiment le résultat de top le 3
octobre et je suis certain dire comment
vous allez regarder un peu et voir le
baromètre justement dit autochtone et le
poids en kilos sur la province du québec
alors je souhaite une bonne semaine
n'hésitez pas à partager notre vidéo et
surtout n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer des
questions si l'on avait même